so let's go one step further past the
decorator pattern that we built up just
now since the object we are decorating
is a brand new empty object it kind of
seems like we could just ask the
car-like function to build it for us in
the first place
that is where classes come in the only
difference between the decorator code
that you see here and a class is that a
class builds the object that it's going
to augment whereas a decorator accepts
the object it's going to augment as an
input so if we move the object creation
into the car like function and remove
the obturator in favor of declaring a
local variable then we would have what's
known as a class and we would give it a
different sort of name to reflect that
fact so a class is a construct that is
capable of building a fleet of similar
objects that all conform to roughly the
same interface it's conventional to name
your class with a capitalized noun
almost like a proper noun for a category
of things the functions that produce
these fleets of similar objects are
called constructor functions because
their job is to construct the objects
that will qualify as members of the
class so to recap the class is the
notion of a category of things that
you'd like to build and all of the
entailed code that supports that
category whereas the constructor is
simply the function that you use to
produce a new instance of that class the
objects that get returned from these
constructor function invitations those
are called instances instances of the
class so when we call a constructor
function in order to create an instance
that operation is known as instantiating
at this point we've reached an example
of the functional class pattern because
we have a simple function that produces
instances of the car class